I think the only thing I'd add to that
is if you look at the dividends versus
the buybacks so the numbers I looked at
yesterday I think I have these right is
about 52% the SP 52% of free cash flow
went to share buybacks the reason why
that's so high I think is because
executive compensation is tied to it and
I and my guess here is people rail
against it so much because the easier
the harder thing to do would be to rail
against the Board of Directors and say
hey you should make the compensation
right you shouldn't tie the share price
or earnings per share etc and so the
incentives are off well the only thing
that the clinical public or those that
aren't on the board can really rail
against when it's an industry-wide thing
is oh the share buybacks the problem and
so what I don't know is is there another
solution than just railing against the
share buybacks where you actually go
after the compensation structures
because if you change the incentives to
your point the share buyback and idibon
is completely the same thing right so if
you go check out all these fa Q's on my
blog post it attacks almost every one of
these mists and there's much more
in-depth academic people that have
damodaran from nyu matheson we mentioned
Cliff Asness on and on and on talk about
each in some cases some of these myths
one by one and one of the studies and
I'm making it precisely wrong is that
they looked at the EPS and company doing
buybacks and not and it was no
difference right the companies that were
tying at the EPS weren't doing more
buybacks than the one that weren't that
haven't been said it's a stupid metric
right Warren Buffett most of these good
CEOs capital allocators there's a great
book called The Outsiders could write
down on a napkin in probably five
minutes a compensation structure that
made sense that's not tied to short term
stock price but rather long term
performance of the company and that's
not that hard I just think it's a boogie
boogie man a demonization that people
like to latch on to like I mentioned a
very simple answer is look I don't care
but think about what happened so it's
like elizabeth warren and others came
out and said we're gonna make buybacks
illegal I say okay you know what you
just did you just said CEO has a lot
more cash on his hands what do you think
he's gonna do with it he's gonna go
spend it he's gonna pay himself more
he's gonna pay his execs more he's gonna
go buy a jet he's gonna go acquire other
companies an empire built right in
thanks so that's the last thing you want
to be doing so it's it's tough because
you know there's a lot of things that
people like to call attention to that
just it doesn't hold up in the data and
so I kind of borrowed myself on Twitter
sometimes I can't help myself
but almost every one of those myths you
can go down down down the list and say
no that's actually not true or the data
says this the data says that but again
it goes back to the CEOs only job is to
maximize where he's using that cash and
so is it paying down dead it could be is
it new projects maybe
is it the buybacks our dividend like all
these things that's his job and you know
it's a topic that's emotionally charged
right now because we're talking about
bailouts for example and let's be clear
if the government steps in and there's a
long case study history of this or the
right way to do it you bailout a company
whether it's an airline cruise ship
these stockholders should be zeroed
right the the CEOs the executives that
have executive compensation that's tied
to shares those shares to be worth zero
well that's the way it's always work
that's bankruptcy right company goes
bankrupt the US could easily say look
fine we're gonna backstop some of these
airlines that's fine but your equity is
now zero then it goes to bond holders
etc the crony capitalism comes in where
they say no we're gonna protect the
shareholders that's the whole point of
being an equity shareholders you accept
that risk right stocks go to zero all
the time like we mentioned earlier the
distribution is like a third of them go
to zero and so people like Mark Cuban
love him god bless him but he's like we
bail out some of these companies they
should never be allowed to buy back
stock again it doesn't make any sense
they should not be a lot of big
dividends when either they do with the
cash and by the way you get to be a fat
bloated company those dividends and
bye-bye
guess what happens with them they get
recycled back into the young emerging
growth companies that are employing and
hiring lots of people versus these big
fat bloated ones so anyway it's um look
man it's a topic that just I think is is
emotional and it's something that people
want to latch on to but I just I don't
think there's any there there little
things you could change on the edges but
for the most part and by the way we
haven't mentioned this on the investment
side the number one thing you want to be
attracted to is companies that are
high-quality trading at cheap valuations
and Buffett says this the best thing a
company can do with its cast if it's
trading below intrinsic value and I'm a
quant so you come up quant value metrics
is buy back their own shares because
you're buying back something for 80 60
cents that's trading for a dollar so you
can take this all the way back to the
1920s
we call it shareholder yield but it's
combining dividends and net buybacks so
net of issuance combining the two
together and figuring out dividends are
the most nonsensical investing strategy
on the planet they're tax efficient
inefficient and it's kind of a crappy
way to do value investing it's not a
real value tilt they tend to be
leveraged companies kind of junky you do
the shareholder yield you got a value
filter it's stomped almost all dividend
investing approaches all the way back to
the 20s and in most decades so there's
from the allocator standpoint as well as
the but what you want at the end of the
day is a good business CEOs thoughtful
who's thinking about all the ways to
maximize return and do so in a way by
the way the problem are seeing differs
anti fragile right where a short-term
disruption is not going to zero the
company because those things happen yeah
I think that we actually see eye to eye
on a lot of this in terms of the share
buyback isn't the quote unquote evil
thing right to me it's the bailouts and
really the structure of how the bailouts
happen and the other piece of it too is
you specifically said look the risk you
take as the equity holder is that it can
go to zero right you can get zeroed out
there and again I think that there's a
balance between you know hey we had a
really great business there was this
Black Swan event
we didn't do anything wrong but this
occurred versus I think when people look
at stuff and say hey you have you know
80% of your free cash flow you spent
over the last five years doing the share
buybacks well if you had held that could
weather this then I think the question
really comes down to you know what's the
right answer unfortunately regardless of
how much people want to debate I don't
think there is a right answer it's
that's why there's the debate right is
because many different people have
different perspectives of it but I think
you articulated kind of what that
trade-off there is you know I would love
for politicians to make dividends
tax-free they won't because it generates
revenue for the government anyway look
by the way there's nothing more
predatory that every state has and the
government has the lottery system that
generates tons of revenue but if you're
asked a lawmaker by the way you're
preying on uneducated poor people why
are you doing this and there's plenty of
other systems in the world that have
savings based lotteries that actually
help people save but they're addicted to
the revenue right so it's the same thing
with dividends versus buybacks like a
simple solution overnight it just make
dividends tax rate